[Music]
one of Sue I was surprised you know
Shaquille O'Neal in the movie and it
surprised me because I've met have a
bunch of times and he's such a funny guy
and you put him in a movie you know to
be an actor and he's funny he's great
funnier than any of us yeah
swear to god there's all comedians in
the movie every time you do is seeing
everybody walk away and go Shaq is
funnier than me he's like the nicest
[ __ ] greatest guy and we hung out
with the Shaq and we get and we all play
basketball a lot of us on the set so
you're a fanatic for basket yeah play
all the time all the time and the Shaq's
there so we're like let's let's play
ball with Shaq so we played ball with
Shaq full-court running up and down
Shaq has swatting shots on our face and
we're like yes so I'm so happy to get an
honor to be rejected by Chad okay then
comes this thing so we play basketball
we got to get back to the movie set Shaq
has to take a shower so everyone's like
alright we'll see you later shag in my
head I'm like I got to see Shaq's penis
I mean for historical reasons it's not a
gay thing it's just like got to see that
yeah
like the Grand Canyon or you gotta see
this completely thank you so my plan was
to kind of I hear the shower go on in
the back and I said all right I'm just
gonna in the back of what I thought
you're like in his trailer so it's like
high school and he's showering away just
not you know being the shack down there
in the showers everyone else left I'm
like all right let me see that thing
so I go back there I hear the shower I
start I kind of turn around backwards
and walk backwards a little like walking
backwards you want to look kind of like
I was gonna trick them like I just walk
back within their salt and there's like
a what's up and but no I walking
backwards doing my routine getting
closer to the shower
and then I turn around and I go alright
I gotta see Shaq's thing right now his
bodyguard is there and his bodyguard is
just so strong and big and like this
thick neck bald head
this one eyes looking at me with this
one iron so I said sorry I was just
trying to see Shaq's penis out of here
please don't tell us you act okay this
happened so I see Shaq later on the set
and I was like I guarantee that guy
ratted me out so I said Jack sorry about
that before with the with your security
guard and he goes I don't got a security
guard that was my dick
[Applause]